all the money in the world is directed
by Ridley Scott and stars Michelle
Williams Mark Wahlberg and Christopher
Plummer and is a story of young john
paul Getty the third and his kidnapping
and his mother's attempt to persuade his
grandfather one of the richest men in
the entire world to pay the ransom I had
no idea that Scott was working on this
film I think when most people think
about movies made by him coming out this
year they probably were thinking about
alien covenant all the money in the
world really flew under my radar and it
got national attention when they decided
to replace Kevin Spacey with Christopher
Plummer after the sexual assault
allegations hit the news and it was a
very wise choice because that character
has quite a bit of screen time and it
would have tarnished this movie without
a doubt and I'm glad they did not only
because this is one of Christopher
Plummer's best performances I've ever
seen which is kind of nuts because it
was done in two weeks the man is a
legend for a reason guys but also
because this is one of Ridley Scott's
best films in years I was riveted from
start to finish this is a really top
thriller one that kept my attention one
that kept me on the edge throughout the
entire runtime and that has a lot to do
with the incredible dialog this is a
really well-written script it is very
dialogue heavy and this will probably
test the patience of some viewers this
is not an action thriller there are
sequences that are very intense and very
violent but this is a really smart and
clever thriller filled with fantastic
performances Christopher Plummer will
get a lot of attention because of all
the headlines that came with the
unorthodox way of shooting this movie
obviously this isn't normal
and it's quite impressive how well
stitched together this movie is if you
hadn't have known the only thing that
would clue you in is that Mark
Wahlberg's body mass changes in scenes
with Christopher Plummer he's not quite
as muscular in those scenes as he is in
the scenes with Michelle Williams and
that's really the only clue that you
might have there's one scene where he
may have been acting to a body double of
one of the other actors but it's not
entirely clear it's one of those things
where like
I feel like the majority of audience
members if they had no idea they
wouldn't even notice and like I said
there's a reason that Ridley Scott and
Christopher Plummer are legends these
guys pulled it off they took two weeks
and ten million dollars and they
improved their film I'm assuming because
I know every time I would have seen that
weird makeup looking Kevin Spacey face I
would have been like no they got an
actual old guy to play an old guy but
the performance that I hope is not
overshadowed by all of that news is
Michelle Williams she is so good in this
film so real and as usual she's just
brilliant she's such a great actress she
has to remain in a constant state of
distress throughout the majority of the
film because her son has been kidnapped
and she's constantly trying to convince
this guy to please give them this ransom
money it has to happen otherwise her son
could die
and she goes through all these ups and
downs and Mark Wahlberg's character sort
of like this fixer dealmaker who helps
people get things they need and
sometimes sells things they need or buys
things people you know he's like he's
like that guy that you go to when you
need help with something that you don't
want to go to the authorities about and
he sometimes has to deliver some rather
horrible information to Michelle
Williams character and the
back-and-forth between the two was
extremely exciting I would say my only
issue with the film beyond the fact that
it is a little long and sometimes you do
feel that runtime is that they didn't
really give us too many concrete reasons
to care about the boy who's kidnapped
he's just kind of kidnapped and you have
to be like okay I feel empathy because
this is a true story and I wouldn't want
this to happen to anybody and so you
naturally feel empathetic for the
characters but I don't know I think it
could have just used a little more
emotion in that area but beyond that
this is a riveting dialogue heavy
thriller that I found intense and
thrilling and extremely enjoyable and
it's a great feel bad time with the
movies for this Christmas I love that
the movies are open on Christmas by the
way I'm gonna give all the money in the
world and a
for what they went through in filming
this movie and the last-minute changes
this film holds up incredibly well and I
think it's one of Scott's best in years
it's filled with Oscar worthy
performances I hope you guys do check it
out thank you so much as always for
watching I do have at least one more
review coming to you before year's end
as well as my best and worst of lists
thanks guys and as always if you liked
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]